[Music]
6 44 on a friday morning you're looking
live at the welcome to las vegas sign
and what you're seeing there is the
culmination of a run this morning to pay
tribute to fallen nhp trooper micah may
as we mentioned earlier in the program
they started running up at the west gate
down to the welcome to las vegas sign
they've gotten to their destination they
were taking some pictures there
to mark the end of the run so the run
started as you see here this morning
cadets from the nevada department of
public safety law enforcement academy
started running took him about an hour
to get down to the welcome sign and as i
mentioned they just ended their run a
few moments ago
it's showing his importance not just to
those of us that worked with them but to
the future state troopers
that
his
not just his
sacrifice but but his service what is
being honored today
trooper travis smacker with nevada
highway patrol the cadets were wearing
are wearing special t-shirts in trooper
maze memory if you're interested in
buying one from the injured police
officers fund you can do that we have
information on our website the proceeds
of that are benefiting the may family
may died last month trying to stop a
carjacking suspect on i-15
yesterday the injured police officers
fund teamed up with nhp to hold this
donation drive to support trooper may's
family this was at the nevada coin mart
off jones in flamingo selling memorial
t-shirts face masks other memorabilia
again to support the may family we have
more details as i mentioned eight news
now dot com